[Music]
on this Sunday night the search for
missing flood victims after epic
rainfall in Nova Scotia we've dedicated
a lot of resources today to
to help find those families
and the long recovery ahead for swamped
residents this was down in my barn down
there and it was fully submerged in
Water Mass evacuation on the Greek
island of Rhodes horrendous is
absolutely I've never been so scared my
entire life thousands of locals and
tourists flee out of control wildfires
solving a covid mystery science that
could explain why some had no symptoms
after infection
and remembering the Gimli glider the
cockpit went black we just heard a loud
bomb
and had no training in this at all one
of the most remarkable moments in
Canadian Aviation
global national with foreign assert
reporting tonight Chris gayles
good afternoon thanks for joining us and
we start today in Nova Scotia where the
search continues for four missing people
after their vehicles were submerged by
flood waters early Saturday morning RCMP
say two children one Youth and a man are
still unaccounted for in the Hants
County region about 45 minutes outside
of Halifax last night an underwater
search located a red pickup truck the
children are believed to have been
traveling in no one was inside crews are
still searching the area hoping to find
all four people and in an attempt to
lower water levels pumping equipment has
been mobilized
to the families you have an entire
Province praying for your loved one safe
return
I know to to Nova scotians I know so
many of you want to help it's the blue
noser way but again given the
treacherous conditions the RCMP
continues to ask people to stay away
from the area
Nova Scotia Premier Tim Houston says
hundreds of people are still evacuated
and the province has submitted a request
for federal assistance Callum Smith
joins us now with the latest on the
destruction
it's up in the choices up here
about this high up you can see the Mark
here
and that's about two inches from my
floor that's how high the water was in
Gary Hutchins basement the 79 year old
Brooklyn Nova Scotia native is now stuck
trying to deal with the mess and the
stuff you know I gather up all your life
right my water pump shot
water tanks done water softeners done
washer dryer is done that trees are full
of foods done
well I'd say the furnace is done he's
not alone homes like this one battered
by the storm
well heavy rainfall was predicted no one
expected this more than 250 millimeters
of rain in some areas in less than 24
hours
The Joint rescue coordination Center
sharing this video of Crews working in
the worst elements in the name of Public
Safety that's something ground search
and rescue crews are up against too
we've been doing Wellness checks uh
evacuations of river valleys
and flood watch and now we're involved
in an active search for missing
individuals one of the biggest
challenges for Crews ahead in the days
and weeks is rebuilding infrastructure
like this bridge that has washed out
behind me on the Evangeline Trail
on the infrastructure side Premier Tim
Houston saying Sunday afternoon that 25
Bridges have been compromised six
destroyed only realizing some of the
storm's impacts after touring some of
the impacted areas last night
and again this afternoon all I can
really say is is thank you thank you
thank you to our incredible First
Responders they're taking very heroic
Measures and and they're entering into
dangerous situations to keep to keep us
safe meanwhile in Bedford cars remain
submerged after the local mall took a
beating Sunday cleanup efforts were
underway with water levels receding but
back in Hance County that challenge is
just beginning you're just discouraged
it's just one piece at a time well I've
seen it all on TV before but I never
thought it happened to me a daunting
task ahead as people try to rebuild and
repair Callum Smith Global News Brooklyn
Nova Scotia
NBC efforts are ramping up to combat the
province's historic Wildfire season with
more International Help on the way in
Abbotsford the BC government welcomed
another batch of firefighters arriving
today from Brazil that's on top of more
than 500 International firefighters who
have already stepped in to help
thousands of local Personnel across the
province there are nearly 500 active
fires burning across BC in what's now
the most destructive Wildfire season on
record more than half of those fires
remain out of control
and out of control wildfires in Greece
have displaced thousands of people on
the Isle of Roads authorities say They
carried out the largest peacetime
evacuation in the country's history more
than 3 000 locals and tourists fled for
safety as intense Flames fanned by
extreme heat approached towns and
Resorts as Redmond Shannon shows us many
people were forced to sleep on beaches
or streets
lining up on a beach in the middle of
the night with flames lighting up the
sky just behind them thousands of
tourists waiting for help after fleeing
hotels on the island of Rhodes at about
three o'clock in the afternoon we could
see Flames coming over the top of the
the forest in Rhodes it is horrendous
there's absolutely I've never been so
scared my entire life vacationers like
these are the lucky ones they managed to
find a Bed others slept on beaches or
streets with nighttime temperatures
hovering above 30 degrees the smoke was
coming so we all set off on foot
I walked 12 miles in this Heat yesterday
it took me four hours along with 800
seven or eight hundred other people the
chaotic evacuation effort on an island
that can often have more tourists than
residents
the fire department says 3 000 people
were taken off the island by sea a
further 16 000 moved elsewhere within
the island the largest evacuation of its
type in Greek history with no injuries
reported Greece relies heavily on
tourism supporting a fifth of its
economy the safe movement of visitors
sits in contrast to the deaths of
hundreds of people in the migrant ship
disaster in Greek Waters last month an
investigation continues into the role
Greek authorities played in the sinking
on roads there is little sign of the
fires abating as the forecast remains
sweltering in a record-breaking Heat
Wave baking countries across southern
Europe some tourists have decided to
leave voluntarily to beat the rush
should their hotels be threatened to try
to find the flight but it's fully booked
everything
but Rhodes residents who have lost their
homes have nowhere to go climate change
is driving hotter and hotter summers in
Greece the heat making wildfires more
frequent and potentially reshaping where
and when tourism is tolerable Redmond
Shannon Global News London and more
wildfires have also prompted new
evacuation orders on the Greek island of
Corfu at least 18 regions there are
impacted meanwhile temperatures reaching
52 degrees Celsius South of the Border
today according to the National Weather
Service California is seeing the highest
temperatures nearing 130 degrees
Fahrenheit excessive heat warnings are
in place there as well as parts of
Florida Arizona Utah and Nevada the
record-breaking heat will continue
throughout the weekend temperatures
while still hot are expected to come
down a bit next week closer at least to
the average
Odessa takes a pounding coming up the
world heritage site targeted by Russian
forces and how locals rushed in trying
to save it plus Miracle Landing how hero
Pilots saved the day 40 years ago when
their passenger jet ran out of fuel over
Manitoba
Russian forces continue to pound the
Ukrainian port city of Odessa for days
it is in your non-stop airstrikes in
retaliation for recent attacks on Crimea
and the attacks have now also damaged
one of the country's most important
Heritage sites Mackenzie gray has more
on the latest round of Destruction and
the toll it's taking on ukrainians
through the third straight night Odessa
is under siege as the Russian
bombardment has yet to let up Ukraine
military officials say air defenses shot
down five cruise missiles and 13 drones
but that only held up a fraction of the
Russian Firepower
the missiles setting the largest church
in Odessa on fire the Transfiguration
Cathedral consecrated in 1809 and when
daylight came over the recently
designated UNESCO world heritage site
the full extent of the damage could be
seen the church's main Atrium collapsed
debris
I think it ought to be quite clear to
everyone in the world right now that
Russia is using food as a weapon of War
not just against Ukraine people but
against all the people in the world
especially the most underdeveloped
countries who depend on grain for them
from the region Putin meant today with
one of his only allies
Poland
this video appearing to show Wagner boss
is getting progosian addressing his
fighters in Belarus the first time he's
been seen since his march on Moscow last
month but it likely won't be the last
time we hear from him with burgosian
saying he's preparing his troops for a
possible return to the war
Global News
the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu will be discharged from
hospital tomorrow after receiving a
pacemaker during an emergency heart
procedure he says he is doing
excellently and plans to attend the key
judicial reform vote in Parliament
foreign
across the country ahead of that vote
they want the prime minister to scrap a
bill that would limit the Supreme
Court's Powers Israel's highest court is
the only source of scrutiny over the
government's use of power critics where
the reforms will undermine democracy and
open the door to corruption and abuse
netanyahu's coalition government says
the bill is necessary to balance out the
branches of power
yeah the people of Spain are heading to
the polls for a snap election that could
see another European country shift
further to the right voters braved
soaring summer temperatures to get their
ballots in with initial results showing
a conservative popular party approaching
a slim majority if it holds they'll
likely seek a coalition with a far-right
party to form government which would be
a first since dictator Francisco Franco
ruled nearly 50 years ago Spain's
left-wing incumbent leader called the
snap election in May after a string of
defeats in local and Regional elections
[Music]
research helps explain why some get sick
and some don't
foreign
19 made an irreversible and ongoing
impact on the world millions of people
have died from the virus or were
hospitalized While others are dealing
with long covet but there are still a
lot of questions about the virus
including why some of the infected never
exhibits symptoms as Elizabeth Nogales
reports a recent study reveals it could
all come down to your genetics
nearly 30 000 people were selected for
the study between February 2020 and
April 2021. they were selected from a
bone marrow donor database the study
published in nature science journal on
Wednesday found that those who
contracted covid-19 and didn't get sick
may have a mutated Gene that assist the
immune system during early infections
researchers discovered individuals with
a mutated human leukocyte antigen Gene
are more than twice as likely to not get
sick from the virus and those who had
two copies of the gene were more than
eight times more likely to remain
asymptomatic however the gene variant
does not stop the virus from entering
the body but it prevents people from
developing cold and flu-like symptoms
Colin furnace an infection control
epidemiologist says this proves that
asymptomatic people can indeed still
spread the covid-19 virus but it will
help for medical advancement we know
that some people seem to get covered
easily and some people don't we know
that there's got to be anything but
we've all been focused on what are the
predictors of severe disease imagine we
had a diagnostic test that would say you
could get covered bad or you will never
get coded bad that would be amazing
furnace adds asymptomatic individuals
aren't invulnerable like Superman in
fact they cause a huge risk to those
around them he hopes that these findings
pave the way for future diagnostic
testing and therapeutic advances
Global News Montreal
oh that's the amazing story of the
Ghibli glider a passenger jet that ran
out of fuel and I was Canadian Pilots
prevented a disaster 40 years ago
The barberheimer Craze has taken
theaters by storm as two Blockbusters
smash box office records this weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
Barbie the movie based on the titular
doll has grossed a staggering 337
million dollars since debuting a few
days ago marking this year's largest
movie opening worldwide Oppenheimer the
Epic about the inventor of the atomic
bomb also earned more than 170 million
dollars one of the biggest debuts for an
R-rated biographical film ever The Surge
is being fueled by glowing reviews and
fan-driven double features inspired by
the wildly different movies releasing on
the same day
well 40 years ago Canadians were gripped
by an unforgettable moment in our
aviation history a passenger jet on its
way to Edmonton had just run out of fuel
29 000 feet over Manitoba due to a
refueling error it could have been
disastrous but as Global's Catherine
Dorian reports skilled Pilots turned the
powerless aircraft into what became
known as the Gimli glider an event the
community still remembers today
40 years ago today a small Manitoba Town
witnessed an incredible feat of Aviation
a Boeing 767 made an unexpected landing
at the gimley race track the cockpit
went black
and had no training in this at all Bob
Pearson was piloting Air Canada Flight
143 when it ran out of fuel halfway from
Montreal to Edmonton despite both
engines failing he was able to Glide for
17 minutes before safely bringing the
jet down artzook was riding his bike on
the track and suddenly found the plane
barreling down on him it all happened so
quickly that we didn't really have time
to process what was going on we were 14
and 11 at the time so we were processing
information as well anyway and you know
we didn't
we didn't perceive that there was
anything
dangerous afterwards it was a rush to
help and put up the fire in the cockpit
we were all Frozen for a second or two
and then a little smoke started drifting
out of the nose gear compartment uh so
we immediately sprung into action
grabbed some fire extinguishers and
started running towards the aircraft I
told my dad I'm like hey what's with the
airplane I was like 13 and he's like
it's an airport and I'm like I know it's
an airport Dad look at that plane
despite everything all 61 passengers and
eight crew escaped with no serious
injuries
four years later area residents call it
the event that put gaming on the map
it's a story that keeps on delivering
Joy especially for Captain Pearson he
met his partner Pearl who was a
passenger at the 30th Anniversary event
a celebration of success despite all the
odds that will keep being told in Gimli
for many more decades Catherine Dorian
Global News
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Chris gayles thanks
very much for watching tonight's your
Canada is lundbc will be back on the
desk tomorrow hope you have a great
evening
[Music]